[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 31 mars bienvenue dans
cette édition spéciale sur tv 78 comme
chaque soir consacrée à la crise
sanitaire du coronavirus dans les
yvelines
le point pour commencer sur la situation
de la pandémie dans le département le
nombre de victimes du coc vide 19 qui
continue d'augmenter
selon les dernières données publiées
hier sur le site du gouvernement 80
personnes sont décédées dans les
hôpitaux yvelinois 11 décès
supplémentaires en 24 heures 132
personnes étaient encore hier en
réanimation sur le territoire sur un
total de 594 hospitalisation à noter que
dans ses statistiques négatives 45
yvelinois supplémentaires en 24 heures
ont pu retourner à leur domicile suite à
une amélioration de leur état de santé
les hôpitaux franciliens sont quasi
saturé il reste actuellement un peu plus
de 300 lits de réanimation en ile de
france c'est pourquoi deux tgv
médicalisé doivent partir de paris cette
semaine à bord environ 40 patients
gravement malades qui vont être
acheminés vers les hôpitaux de régions
moins touchées par le coronavirus
plusieurs équipes soignantes seront
présents pour accompagner les soins le
personnel médical totalement engagé dans
la bataille contre le virus et la région
ile de france se mobilise pour être à
leurs côtés écoutez à ce propos la
présidente de la collectivité valérie
pécresse alors nous nous mobilisons
d'abord pour nos personnels soignants
nous avons dégagé 18 millions d'euros
pour que tous les étudiants infirmiers
qui dépendent de la région puissent
rejoindre l'hôpital l'hôpital en ile de
france a besoin de bras a besoin de
ressources humaines pour les personnels
soignants en ville qu'ils sont mais
aussi nos bouclier contre l'épidémie
la région a mis en place un fonds de 10
millions d'euros est d'urgence et nous
réglons sur facture tous les équipements
que pharmaciens médecins infirmiers
libéraux pourraient avoir à acheter
pour lutter contre le coc vide et par
ailleurs nous avons financé une ligne
d'écouté et de soutien psychologique
pour les personnels soignants justement
parce qu'ils sont très rudement
aujourd'hui mis à l'épreuve
la présidente de la région ont évoqué le
cas de ces étudiants en médecine
mobiliser également pour renforcer les
effectifs médicaux pendant la pandémie
pour les aider et surtout les protéger
l'université versailles saint quentin
leur distribuant en ce moment et des
masques et des gants la démarche a été
mené la semaine dernière et s'est
poursuivie ce matin à lui être faire des
sciences de la santé à montigny le
bretonneux hattrick jacques de dixmude
pour les images censées masque ou ses
gants de protection un possible de
prêter main forte au monde de la santé
pendant cette période de crise sanitaire
plusieurs étudiants de l'ub est ce qu
ils n'ont ainsi pas pu débuter leur
stage chez les médecins généralistes
faute de matériel ce matin-là ils
reçoivent de la part de leur université
une boîte de 50 grands et 50 masques qui
ont chacun une durée de quelques heures
seulement si on n'avait pas ça on ne va
pas la possibilité de les faire les
faire travailler on peut pas les envoyer
au front sans un minimum de de
protection individuelle parce qu'ils
soient réellement en première ligne par
rapport aux patients qui sont
potentiellement infectées a lu vs q les
stocks de masques constitué il ya
plusieurs années suite à l'épidémie de
h1n1 ont été vite épuisé l'université
versailles saint quentin a pu profiter
d'une dotation de 80 boîtes de l' agence
régionale de santé et du matériel avait
déjà été distribué la semaine dernière
on est quand même confrontée à plusieurs
malades et donc et des personnes qui
sont plutôt fragile donc pour les
protéger pour nous protéger
je pense que c'est essentiel c'est vrai
que c'est un petit peu difficile en
ville d'avoir démasqué donc là on est on
est bien content de pouvoir en avoir
chacun chacun une boîte quand on est en
stage chez le médecin généraliste trois
médecins généralistes mois chez qui je
vais donc ils n'ont pas forcément de
masques pour moi déjà que pour eux c'est
compliqué donc on est content de pouvoir
se protéger et protéger les autres
l'université versailles saint quentin
espèrent désormais une nouvelle dotation
de la part de la rs dans une quinzaine
de jours les forces de l'ordre
totalement mobilisés en cette crise
sanitaire du colis de 19 ans notamment
avec des policiers des gendarmes
directement au contact de la population
lors des contrôles des attestations de
déplacement dérogatoire les policiers
qui sont notamment inquiets en cette
période on va en parler avec julien le
cam bonsoir mais enfin vous êtes le
secrétaire régional d'alliance police
nationale dans les yvelines
alors nos confrères du parisien relatait
dans leur édition du week-end une
situation
chaotique pour les policiers dans les
yvelines ya près d'un millier de
policiers qui seraient indisponibles
dans le département selon plusieurs
syndicats est ce que c'est une situation
que vous confirmez la situation est très
difficile aujourd'hui pour les policiers
dans les yvelines
alors en fait le fonctionnement est
particulier en ce moment des des
commissariats on se concentre sur
l'urgence les interventions urgentes et
notamment les aussi les contrôles de des
différentes attestations montrent les
points de contrôle alors c'est pas tout
à fait mille fonctionnaires hors service
il faut savoir que parmi ces mille
fonctionnaires et on a quasiment 700 qui
sont ce qu'on appelle en réserve
c'est à dire c'est les fonctionnaires
qui sont à domicile 1 et qui seront
utilisées donc en remplacement des
fonctionnaires et potentiellement
touchées par une maladie il y a à peu
près 300 fonctionnaires par contre en
arrêt maladie sur le département et qui
pour l'instant n'impacte pas le
fonctionnement
ce qu'on appelle en mode dégradé des
commissariats donc en arrêt maladie ils
sont ils ont été testés positifs au
coronavirus papa que alors pas tous
malheureusement défaut de test lassé des
fonctionnaires qui sont placés en arrêt
maladie par leur médecin traitant
un vice qui présentent des symptômes
donc par précaution si les
fonctionnaires qui sont placés en arrêt
maladie
est ce que le quel est l'état du moral
on imagine que c'est un moral qui est
qui n'est pas au beau fixe aujourd'hui
non du tout il faut savoir que mes
collègues justement le moral bas on le
voit les carences de l'administration et
de l'état mais faut il aimer mes
collègues ont fait face au début donc dû
justement du confinement a aucun
matériel de protection
donc il était très difficile pour eux
justement de procéder au contrôle des
attestations en respectant les gestes
barrière c'est très difficile il faut
savoir que vous avez des secteurs 1 les
personnes ne respectent pas un tout de
suite je vous avez un contact vous avez
une discussion un peu virulente et mes
collègues n'ont pas de masque et ni de
gants etc ce qui forcément créer un gros
problème chez nous c'est ce manque de
considération et ce manque de matériel
donc un manque de matériel et aussi
parfois on certaine
donne des yvelines quelques quelques
soucis rencontrés par par vos collègues
il ya eu quelques quelques agressions
quelques insultes aussi qui ont été
proférées à l'encontre des policiers
ah bah il faut savoir que ce que vous
vivez ce que l'on vit depuis des années
c'est à dire ceux voilà ce sentiment on
va dire de laxisme de la justice qui est
en fait durant confinement qui ne
s'arrête pas il faut savoir que pour
procéder à des contrôles d'identité ou
des contrôles pas d'attestation c'est
toujours très difficile vous avez des
individus qui n'acceptent pas ce
contrôle qui n'acceptent pas ce
confinement notamment dans les quartiers
difficiles à on voit mes collègues à
trappes qui ont été carrément agresser
lors d'un contrôle de l'attestation on a
trois collègues qui avaient été blessés
à ce moment là il faut savoir que les
individus ne s'arrête pas au confinement
ni à une pandémie
1 nous avons malheureusement laissé sa
ces individus ce sentiment d'impunité
continue malgré de confinement est donc
vous parler on va terminer avec ceux de
ce manque de protection je crois que ce
sont 300 mille masques qui était attendu
au niveau national aujourd'hui il ya des
distributions qui était prévue cet après
midi dans les yvelines
c'est ça alors notre syndicat alliance
police nationale a récupéré un stock via
une grande enseigne de vêtements un
stock de douze mille masques donc cet
après midi je vais récupérer deux mille
masques pour les policiers yvelinois que
j'irai remettre à la ddsp à la direction
départementale pour une distribution
rapide dans les services parce qu'il
faut savoir que malheureusement au
niveau national nous devons nous battre
avec peu de moyens et justement notre
organisation met tout en oeuvre pour
récupérer appel aux dons et nous
procédons donc à des distributions pour
pallier aux manquements de
l'administration et de l'état donc vous
attendre c'est d'en avoir encore plus la
saison 12 lille aujourd'hui mais c'est
d'en avoir plus pour les prochains jours
oui le
le syndicat alliance police nationale
notre bureau national met tout en oeuvre
pour récupérer au maximum auprès de
sociétés privées auprès de du conseil
général auprès du conseil départemental
ont fait des appels aux dons
et nous irons remettre ses moyens
directement policiers merci julien le
cam d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le secrétaire
régional d'alliance police nationale
dans les yvelines et dans ce contexte de
confinement le monde agricole doit faire
face aussi à la crise sanitaire la
poursuite de son activité est primordial
pour nourrir les français reportage dans
une exploitation à plaisir qui prépare l
oea prochaine culture pour l'année
patrick jacques de dixmude et nicolas
dandois sans confinement jérôme regnault
le vit la plupart du temps dans son
tracteur cet exploitant basée à plaisir
poursuit son activité agricole malgré la
crise sanitaire préparation des semis de
céréales le programme de ce début de
saison printanier on vient de passer une
dizaine de jours avec un vent de
nord-est qui a vraiment tout ça tout à
sécher donc c'est un petit peu assez ni
les terres sur les sur les premiers
jours ça nous a permis en bonne
condition de semer les orges de
printemps les féveroles moi je fais
partie de ceux qui font de la féverole
c'est à dire la protéine pour nos
animaux
on se prépare par avance pour les ter à
maïs avant qu'elle sèche trop les
travailler en amont et on laisse aimera
d'ici une quinzaine de jours à peu près
à ses côtés de salariés sont engagés au
sein de son exploitation avec quelques
modifications dans l'organisation du
travail dans ce contexte particulier
chacun sa mission c'est vrai que
d'habitude on travaille beaucoup plus
ensemble
là c'est chacun sa mission son outil son
tracteur et puis dans une cabine au
moins toute la sécurité et la cette
crise entraîne aussi un changement de
regard sur l'agriculture
pour jérôme raynier au créateur de la
plateforme des changes ici la terre
cette période permet aux français de
réfléchir sur les produits agricoles
on prend le temps de la réflexion prend
le temps de se poser et les gens ont
réalisé cette nécessité d'avoir une
agriculture locale responsable qui peut
le ramener des produits bien sûr
d'alimentation courante mais surtout de
qualité est garantie sanitaire
moralement on se sent un petit peu plus
apprécié je le vois par les coups de fil
qu'on reçoit sur le numéro vert mais je
le vois aussi
dans des publicités par des messages de
nos de nos élus ministres de
l'agriculture ministre de l'économie
face à la nécessité de main d'oeuvre
dans le secteur le ministre de
l'agriculture et la fnsea ont lancé un
appel aux personnes confinées pour aider
les agriculteurs sur leur exploitation
en attendant la mise en ligne de cette
plate forme gouvernementale qui doit
intervenir dans les prochaines heures
une autre est déjà active des bras pour
ton assiette est le site with iphone qui
se présente comme un écosystème de
solutions numériques recense les
missions et besoins des agriculteurs et
viticulteurs
vous pouvez leur prêter main-forte si
vous avez du temps libre sur le site il
suffit de proposer vos services et de
connaître les besoins autour de chez
vous ces missions sont rétribuées à la
plateforme et pour information
partenaires de pôle emploi un mot de
sport nous vous annoncions hier le gel
définitif cette saison des championnats
de rugby amateur en raison bien sûr du
contexte sanitaire et du manque de
visibilité sur les prochaines semaines
d'autres disciplines ont également
décidé de mettre fin à leurs
championnats respectifs pour les
amateurs c'est le cas du tennis de table
dont la fédération s'est prononcé hier
elle la phase 2 de toutes les
compétitions ne pourra pas aller à son
terme une face blanche est donc actée
sans montées descentes les titres
décernés toutes les épreuves prévues
jusqu'à la fin de saison sont également
annulés est les points acquis ou perdus
par les joueurs pour les matchs joués
avant le confinement resteront eux à qui
une décision doit être encore prises
pour la pratique professionnelle
la semaine dernière déjà une décision
similaire a été prise par la fédération
française de handball
ml année de championnat ne sera pas pour
autant blanche si aucun titre ne sera
décerné elle les classements seront eux
arrêtés à date
il y aura donc bien démontés et des
relégations à l'instar du tennis de
table à un choix sera fait dans les
prochains jours pour déterminer la suite
ou non des championnats professionnels
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale merci de l'avoir suivi ces
images pour nous quitter qui vous
mettront sûrement un appétit avant de
passer à table est le chef de maurepas
jean christophe broux dit continue ses
livraisons solidaire pour le père
sonel de l'hôpital mignot du chesnay
rocancourt au menu au saumon fumé
sauvage crème de crabes et requête
restez chez vous et très belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]